welcome to civilization beyond Earth
I am master control constructed in
founding year 122 I am a wonder of this
planet created to provide colonial
administrators with centralized control
for the optimal functioning of their
colonies my capabilities are at your
service since our peoples settlement on
this planet we have grown from fragile
beginnings into our full strength soon
you will have the capability to directly
control the progress of a settlement
writing the future of mankind the fungal
biomes of this world initially presented
many challenges to us despite these
divergent evolutionary patterns we are
now capable of sustaining earth-based
life on this planet as evidenced by
these Terrace caves these precious
gardens permit earth life to thrive here
and are a delight to our people our
faction believes that humanity is good
in and of itself we believe that
humanity holds a special place among the
universe we transform worlds so that
more humans may thrive without resorting
to invasive cybernetics or alien gene
transfusions we are aligned with the
purity affinity deployed solar collector
satellite this unit will increase energy
yield near our capital purity aligned
factions specialize in maximizing yield
within their territories
our culture thrives we have the ability
to develop an additional virtue for our
people by choosing techno artisans part
of our cultural output will be added to
our research total each turn the
expected outcome of this is to
accelerate our research gains I have
detected an active threat native species
bivens bestia insel a colloquial name
kraken defining features gigantism
calcareous outer shell tentacles
grinding kite misspeak largest known
indigenous species right now this kraken
represents an imminent threat to trade
and security commencing attack with
naval fighters direct combat suboptimal
adjusting tactics aerospace fighters
engaging
switching to ranged combat
threat neutralized I have detected a
possible threat vadim petrovitch Kozlov
leader slavic Federation forces amassing
near our borders the Slovak Federation
is aligned with the supremacy affinity
supremacy believes that humanity needs
to be independent of their planetary
biosphere supremacy oriented factions
practice radical augmentation and
extensive Cybernet is a ssin as opposed
to our purity affinity Kozlov likely
intends to destroy our capabilities to
terraform this planet opening direct
diplomatic communications stir cheats on
you ste
threat level elevating my calculations
have determined that a pre-emptive war
declaration will give our faction the
optimal chance for survival
supremacy military forces rely on
positioning and battle space
configuration for optimal attack by
disrupting their formations and using
our orbital attacks we ensure the
survival of our forces
declaring war the VTR anemia Xu Jia Liu
Naboo diminished Street
[Music]
deployed Aegis bipedal combat system
Aegis specializes in fire support and
anti infantry operations planet car
during combat orbit and awaiting orders
authorization for orbital attacks
granted commence firing deploying left
destroyer left destroyers offer
unparalleled firepower and protection
success is inevitable by my calculations
Kozlov must either regroup his surviving
forces or face destruction in our hands
we have achieved security for our people
how shall you direct the future of
mankind standby to assume full
administrative control this is master
control
I am terminating connection
[Music]
you
[Music]